die kabine ist echt und es gibt
[Musik]
ich glaube es sollte dann ist das doch
nur fester ok also herzlich kommen soll
dann wieder leute wie euch natürlich
gesehen das ist heute ein besonderer tag
denn ich werde heute mein erstes video
mit meiner kleinen schwester machen das
heißt das erste video in dem er seine
kleine schwester sehen könnt das andere
video mein bruder wachsen ich habe schon
mit ihr gemacht aber bisher war sie noch
nie zu sehen leute deswegen werde ich
jetzt mal eine kleine schwester zeigen
wir werden zusammen auf eigene folge
hilft mir reagieren und ja heute würde
ich sagen wenn ich jetzt was dagegen
schwester und dann können wir vielleicht
anfang mit der agent das hier weiß man
heute von uns ausgesucht habt heißt
unsere single ladies ich will wie bios
hier seien leute natürlich heute meine
kleine schwester weiß darf ich keine
also fr zufolge raussuchen erst mal
vorneweg kennst du hilft mir ja was ist
hier
es ist finanziell und was macht es wie
fange jetzt so viele leute wie gesagt
bevor der weg weil ich weiß da ist
tatsächlich krankheit ich musste sie aus
der schule abholen hatte dein krank
sagte was damit zu tun dass sie heute
nachmittagsunterricht hast bis 4
[Musik]
und das ist wirklich gut essen verwöhnt
[Gelächter]
natürlich sieht man doch sie spricht
auch deutsch
was keiner weiß eigentlich als der
josefstadt in deinem flossen von meiner
freunde das ist also was machst du denn
mit ihnen
ja das ist der grund genug also meinen
laden zusammen aber derzeit nicht
lieferbar er hat gesagt dann stimme
meiner freundin du hast mit dem nicht
rum zu machen
auf einmal steht gestört wird weiß man
das grundstück ist ganz einfach du
kannst dich verein in herr der ringe
oder du musst gestellt
du hast dich schnauzer gehen gleich
gucken wie ein richtiger mann ist man
muss aber auch sagen
andersrum hätte der spruch glaube ich
nicht so gut integrieren also wenn
ärztliche mission versagt sind also ja
ok aber wenn er zu ihm ist nicht ganz
sein
[Musik]
wir haben druck immer ganz ehrlich das
ist uns beiden hat sowieso keinen sinn
mehr passt viel besser zu mir also nur
auch so einen scheiß 1 fans war es ein
verziehen
dann passiert hallo es ist der chor
konnte sie keine neuigkeiten wieder wort
dazu geben er ist wirklich den kugelkopf
erwartet ihn einfach nicht leisten
hier wird wirklich verwandt
also markus müller ja ich bin der vater
von eminem alter rocker sowie von shawn
carter der mann von josi leute es wären
wenn wir den ball von josias hatte ich
verstehe sich beyoncé sein aber was er
jetzt davon aus dass jetzt wieder der
beste den man von josi den verkehr
[Musik]
nun bringt ob ich wünschte ich wünschte
das wäre so einfach mädels kennen zu
lernen einfach sagen ich bin der bruder
von wer ist gerade so cool in
deutschland im milieu sakral und jetzt
kommt sofort hierhin mein fräulein motiv
weißt du eigentlich wie spät ist es
schon immer sagen woher du jetzt kommt
der geilste zeit meines lebens aber ja
doch das gut brauchen
die die karriere läuft jetzt so läuft
das nur einfach zu sein will dann
einfach den coupon sie versteht es nicht
packen aufs fakt arbeit also erste ko
sorgte sie und dann küsst sie ihn aber
das macht sie
ich habe den anderen kennengelernt
brokat abwehr toccata der gesang von
jaycee wer was das ist mit meinem auto
mama jaycee rokoko rck und dann carter
sowie die katze sind okay aber
wirst du siehst du geld ist ja genau die
gleiche person was das was das für eine
gestaltet alter junge diese marken
komplett gesundheit ich man kann es
wieder ein ganz junger rennfahrer kann
sich unterhalten den schieberegler für
die leute stärker beim macbook gras
leute soll ich auch mal mason zu teller
unsere dunkler wow der hausarrest hat
alter junge ist also immer eine tür
haben zuletzt einfach da ist dann
einfach
sie hat das einfach gar keine kurven
aber dann kann sie meinen rausgelassen
[Musik]
das ist so ein apple google könnte ich
auch super weiter nicht krank gut das
sollte nicht alles einmal für den beweis
[Musik]
der ist nicht nur wir uns ist das ist
nicht die nicht aus selbst und dessen
ist scheint aber da habe ich dabei aus
dem kamin aus leidenschaft für bios geht
über normales fernsehen weit hinaus sie
möchte ganz genau so sein wie ihr großes
vorbild
ich frage mich woher diese fixe idee
kommt und wie weit china noch gehen wird
antwort sehr weit müssen wir jetzt werde
ich rechne mit dem schlimmsten
leute haben schon 20 minuten aufgenommen
ist es ein bisschen so wie es kippen
das glaube ich dir jetzt aber irgendwie
nicht hätte ich also du meinte auch mal
es ist kalt
derweil wertet den konnte ich sie kenne
und jeder hält wird einfach nur keiner
gönnt ihr der cloud lächerlich also
normale menschen können nicht mehr
irgendwo in jersey verschnitt in den
wind schießen weil ich meine da steht
auch hinter dir und du es dir immer treu
gewesen und ganz ehrlich was dein
problem ich meine es für zugegeben lesen
barrick wurde stehen würde und fakt ist
nicht so
so will egal und geht jetzt berühmt
ersten blick könnte man sich überlegen
ist neu aber immer hinterher
du siehst so explosiv wirklich so stimmt
das recht weiter weil sie kennt aber
natürlich essen war es auch einfach der
deutsche jazz
darum geht es nicht
ja es gibt gut aussehen es geht darum
dass er mit beyond mit josef rose
zusammen ist hat ihn zu erreichen den
hinschicken nicht schießen nicht
schießen ist die nächste stufe
[Musik]
ich glaube es doch sollte das dort
verstarb
ok also leute sie ist jetzt irgendwie
hier mit dem blut am start gewusst
eine ganze menge ist kippen aber
schwerlich vieler will nicht verpasst
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es ist das gesetz zurück das was von
diesem wieder meine schwester ist über
seine chance verdient aber wenn ihr mehr
videos mit einer schwesternschaft
reichen die kommentare eindeutig drin
findet ein vorschlag das wiederum könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren sehr vernünftige
entscheidung wenn ja auch bei der suche
guten zeiten wenn wolltet schöner strauß
wie sondern der strauß macht's gut